hey guys merry here and here's all the
games coming out this week if you felt a
little left out when tomb raider came
out on xbox you're about to join in on
the fun because it comes out on pc this
week rise of the Tomb Raider will
support 4k resolution the standard
edition will go for 60 bucks while a
digital deluxe edition featuring the
game and it's DLC pass will sell for 90
it's a freaking great game if you
haven't played it you should that's out
on the twenty-eighth now if you do have
an xbox you can look forward to rise the
tomb raiders first upcoming story
expansion on the twenty-sixth which
sounds like a children's band Baba Yaga
will be playing that the moment it drops
next week also this week Lego continues
its super well timed video game release
with Lego Marvel Avengers the game will
feature over 200 playable characters
Captain America Iron Man Hulk Black
Widow Hawkeye Scarlet Witch Quicksilver
Thor Ultron Loki Winter Soldier Falcon
vision war machine and even double
dinosaur and Fin Fang Foom they're all
here basically if you're a fan of the
Avengers whether it be movies comics or
cartoons you're probably gonna like this
one that's out on the 20 60 but we're
far from done here my friends because
Jonathan Blow the creator of braid is
finally gracing us with his next game
and it looks like a head-scratching
puddler that we've been waiting for the
witness is said to take most people 20
to 25 hours to complete Jonathan Blow
also said that there's a puzzle in the
game that only one percent of people
will be able to solve I heard that the
game adapts the way you think and then
tries to replace your parents in real
life two of those rumors are true and
you can find out which ones on the 26th
but if puzzles make your head hurt and
you like shootie guns in space to thumpy
beats you're gonna want to check out a
ipd which stands for apes in puppy
disguises okay I've been told that the
actual name is artificial intelligence
police department but agree to disagree
a ipd looks like a classic twin stick
shooter but in addition there's co-op
battles with up to four players on one
screen plus it's got those Tron like
visuals and bassy beats that's out on
the twenty-ninth this war of mine is a
survival themed strategy game where the
player controls a group of civilian
survivors in a makeshift shelter in a
besieged war-torn city it was released
in 2014 4 pc but now there's a ps4 and
xbox one release title called this war
of mine the little ones and it adds to
that story with new missions and
character crafts during the day while
avoiding snipers and then venture out at
night for new materials and food but
every time you do that you risk finding
other survivors that might need your
help or they might want to kill you you
can make that call on the 29 you can
also consider the isometric action game
bombshell this week the game revolves
around Shelly bombshell Harrison an
important lady at the global Defense
Force but unfortunately during some
incident she loses her arm and her team
and then she's offered a new contract by
a private military contractor and
offered a second chance and a new
mechanical arm sounds familiar I bet the
private military scrubbed anyway that's
out on the 29th lastly a final fantasy
for 3ds explorers in this game the world
is on the brink of war over the greatest
source of power in the world the grand
crystal players band together to form an
elite squad of explorers who venture out
to collect pieces of the grand crystal
to provide energy for the planet while
fighting off hordes of monsters you go
get those crystals on the twenty-sixth
so that's all the video games coming out
this week that you should know about if
you're interested in the dlc for Tomb
Raider Alexis and I are to be playing
that Tuesday mornings you should check
it out release states are based on
retailer listings and sometimes we
change I'll see you next week